[Music]
[Applause]
Jerome Bettis joining us the Hall of
Fame running back and W a Super Bowl six
Pro bowls and uh 10th overall pick by
the Rams out of Notre Dame back in 1993
busy good to have you back on I want to
play something that uh your former
quarterback Ben rothberger had to say
talking about the Steeler tradition then
I'll get your reaction to this here's
Ben
rothberger I felt that certain guys on
the team aren't in it for the team
they're in it for themselves well now
some of the guys on the team are saying
the same thing so maybe I wasn't too far
off when I said that but I know that I'm
retired I just don't you know I'm not in
the locker I get it but it just feels
like that it just feels like that's
something that's kind of been lost on
this team a little bit you it feels like
the Steeler way is just not they just
wasn't that Steeler tradition passed
down and I just you have it on defense
don't get me wrong but you don't have it
on offense right now and it's it's just
making it really hard you're not seeing
in my opinion the toughness on offense
but I just feel like people aren't
afraid to play the Pittsburgh Steelers
anymore for for whatever you know
whatever that is but maybe the the the
tradition of the Pittsburgh Steelers is
is is is done maybe it needs to be
formed a new kind of way I don't know
it's Ben rothberger his football in
podcast all right Jerome what do you
think uh Ben is getting it well I I
think he's getting at the fact that for
one uh they haven't needed a uh a
quarterback for the last what 14 15
years whatever it was he was there so
there was a lot of continuity between uh
uh kind of eras if you will so for I
don't a I don't necessarily agree with
that I think they have they don't have
the leadership on offense uh you got a
lot of young guys on offense trying to
find their way and that's what you're
seeing it's not that it's you know it's
not the still away is gone uh it's just
that you just don't have uh the
consistency offensively and and that's
what you're seeing out there and that's
the problem um the the leadership
unfortunately you know got a Young
quarterback if he's not in the game then
obviously who's leading the way you know
from an offensive line perspective um
you don't have those those
personalities uh that stepping that's
stepping up and saying hey I'm GNA be a
leader of this offense I'm gonna push us
forward you know and then obviously you
have the wide receiver um uh issues that
you that you're hearing about publicly
uh and so what happens is you just don't
have the leadership on offense on
defense you do and you you heard um Ben
talk about the leadership on defense you
just don't have it on offense and I
think that's what they're missing okay
how would you feel if you were the
running back for the Steelers and your
wide receiver George Pickins is not
blocking anybody on a run where you can
score a touchdown and the guy he's
supposed to be blocking ends up with the
tackle what would you
say I would I will pull him to the side
say come on man listen we all in this
together if you want me to block that
linebacker when it's blitz so he can get
the ball to you I want you to do the
same for me so you wanna you want to
express to them the importance of you
know each and every play right and
so yeah you can come down on them in the
media uh but I promise you that's not
going to turn turn his switch on uh it's
going to be you putting your armor on
him say hey man listen we all into this
together and if you look good we all
look good if you look bad we all look
bad that's the bottom line I think
that's part of that's part of the the
leadership that's missing you just don't
have that that guy to say hey man come
here listen yeah here's the what's
what's Mike tomlin's role in all of this
you're saying the players got to be
accountable so so yeah yeah it's it's a
fine line the head coach it's hard for
him to be the Buddy too
right so he's got to be the heavy in
this in this particular role you need
someone internally in that locker room
that can pull him aside say listen man
I'm in this I'm in the same boat that
you're in I'm with you and so the head
coach can't necessarily play that role
that's why you you need that strong
leader offensively that can pull him
aside say look man we all getting
hammered here so here's the deal we all
got to put more effort for there we all
have to do this and the key word is we
and when you don't have that person
saying we that's where it it falls apart
you know I started to think about
running backs when I knew you were going
to be on that at some point it's going
to be hard to quantify who's a Hall of
Famer because it's probably going to be
more about receptions than it's going to
be about yards like Christian mcaffrey
is he a Hall of
Famer ah wow it's you know what that's a
that's a tough one early in his career
uh you know unfortunately he he didn't
put up those the same numbers that he's
putting up now um you know obviously
injury and that kind of thing so with
him you got to look at longevity you
gota look at you know will he be able to
to do this for 10 12 years uh so that we
can look at his body at work and say
absolutely okay but who's playing now
that you think is going to the Hall of
Fame at running back is Derk Henry a
Hall of Famer right
now he's he still has to do more I think
everybody still has to do more that's
the that's the thing it's not it's not a
clear science one
um I can promise you that uh so that's
that's part of the issue but you also
have to you know have to you know lead
your team from a successful standpoint
now you know they he's made some uh I
think AFC championship games or
something like that so that that bodess
well for him so that that's part of um
all of that that that they look at so I
you know for me to say yeah he's a Hall
of Famer I'd be doing uh the Hall of fam
a disservice if I was and if I said he's
not I'd be doing I'd be doing the player
disservice so I just think they're
they're on the road if they have to just
continue with that with that success for
a long period of time but they're not
going to get to 12,000 rushing yards
that just not going to happen anymore
and it used to be if you got to 10,000
you got into the Hall of Fame and I
don't know if we go back to maybe that
number that's the magical number and you
throw in you know yards some scrimmage
with receptions yeah so so here here's I
think is is what how we have to look at
it you see the
receivers um the goal line has been been
moved um and I say that because I've got
a guy who's who's his goal line has been
moved in Hines Ward he played in an era
where we ran the football right but he
was one of the best uh in that era he
did it all and then at the end of his
era the goal line move because the goal
post move rather because now you got all
these guys you know catching 115 120
balls a year when he was in an era where
when you caught 85 balls a year that put
you at the top of the league so now his
numbers are skewed because he kind of
was in both of those eras so I think
what you look at with the running back
it's going to be a different era in
terms of the numbers so you're going to
look at it a different way and you're
going to look at those numbers a
different way because you know it is a
passing era hin W is a Hall of Famer and
you know what I would do if I'm Mike
Tomlin I ask Hines W to come in to teach
my wide receivers how to be tough and be
multi-dimensional not just come out
there what is it about Diva receivers in
Pittsburgh uniforms and like what's
going on here that's not a diva
town it's not it's not it's a blue
collar town with um with people who love
to to roll their sleeves up and go to
work so yeah that that is it's an issue
it's a concern uh but you know that's
one of those because you don't have that
guy to say hey man listen you know get
your ass in gear let's go man bring in
hin Ward just bring him in or just show
video of Hines Ward and just say that's
that's all you got to show that's what I
would do that's what I would do no doubt
about it did Hines ever hit you
accidentally he hit me all the time we
always had to we had a a little thing we
would do that you know about touchdowns
whoever scored the touchdown right and
so we would yell no no if he was going
in or if I was going in and it was a
funni thing because everybody thought we
were we hated each other but it was it
was this little thing that we used to do
uh trying to beat each other at the
touchdown so there was a there was maybe
a time or two where he um he he he said
he was trying to help push me in the end
zone he was just giving me a shot he's
Jerome bet Us by the way Jerome has a
blue and gold Golf Classic that takes
place in the Hamptons next May 20th and
21st so uh the event benefits Notre Dame
endowment and the bus stops here
Foundation more information blue and
gold
classic.com would you have switched
positions coming into the NFL if like
like if you were coming out of Notre
Dame
now would you be drafted high as a
running
back wow that's a great I don't think so
well I I think uh I would be drafted
about no not the 10th pick in in the
draft like uh I have been um because I
think right now you have to be so
Dynamic uh catching the football I think
that becomes part of um uh your your DNA
it has to be and when you look at the
guys who've been drafted High that's
that's a big part of what they do so I
think when we look at Christian mcaffrey
he's kind of identified what the new uh
running back should look like right what
he should be what what characteristics
he should have but I will say this uh
what people don't really notice about
Chris mcaffrey and I've watched him ever
since he was in Carolina he's a really
good Insider Runner um I watched him
when he was at Stanford they he is and
so a lot of people think because of his
size you know he's he's he's a really
good in between the tackles Runner and I
think that's what you have to be to play
in the NFL you can't be a guy that plays
on the edge you've got to be a guy who's
a downhill in between the tackle guy in
order to have that kind of success you
don't have to be the biggest guy in the
world but you've got to know how to to
um to work your way U on a on the
football field in between the tackles
that that hurt Reggie Bush that he
wasn't a you know between the tackles
kind of running back and and mcaffry is
built different than Reggie Bush but
Reggie wasn't a between the tackles
running back that's right and and in the
NFL the difference here is is in college
you're you're faster than you know a lot
of the guys on the edge because a lot of
those guys won't make it to the NFL
right well in the NFL every guy deserves
to be there and every guy has has that
Talent so you're not gonna run some
outrun somebody to the to the edge to
the corner you you gotta get in you go
inside to get outside and that's what
that's what um the the running backs in
the NFL that's the biggest difference
from college to Pro you have to learn
you have to run inside to get outside if
you don't do that it won't ever happen
you got to be able to make a guy Miss
and I think when you look at the the
great running backs they've always had
the ability to make a guy Miss because
there's the guy is going to be where
he's supposed to be that's the NFL these
guys are are on defense they're talented
uh they're disciplined so they're GNA be
there is you got to be able to make a
miss and so I think when you look at
Christian mcaffrey he does that ex
exceptionally well uh or you gotta be
able to run him over like Dereck
hry do you still have a beef with
anybody that cheap shotted you no I
don't I don't I I I had I had you know
my my group of guys there was some know
a guy here I it was a guy for the
Chargers who I was always after uh a
couple guys from the Titans that I was
always after but but uh give me a name
give me a name no no no no I'm not gonna
do it I'm not gonna do it I I I kind of
I I turned uh you try to take me back to
the dark side no I have turned that
chapter okay all right all
right but I tell you what yeah if I if I
saw him on the street I I would do a
double take like do I do I go in and
give a forearm shiver
or I like that bus told me one time a
couple years ago that he could actually
hear a guy kind of whimper when he ran
into him a defensive player right yes
that was that was fun because obviously
you you don't get that many
opportunities but how did it sound when
you run into this defensive player you
see them and you and you you're breaking
their wheel so you can kind of hear it
it's like
and it's just a long like hurt that you
can kind of feel and when you look at in
the eyes then they don't want to look at
you that's when you know you have broken
their will and you don't even have to
worry about that guy anymore you know
he's he's gonna make it look like he's
trying to dive but he's diving straight
to the ground he wants you to jump over
we bring up your your run against Brian
irocker whenever we see ear Locker we
always bring up the Drome Bettis run and
he's like oh why you got to bring that
up we bring up when Tom Brady uh you
know shifted uh you know kind of deed
him there and then we always bring up
you running over ear
Locker yeah he is he's pissed off about
that to this day um but what I will I
tell him that hey think about this we we
exchanged shoes after the game so he has
that the shoes that actually that ran
them over so how many guys in the
history of the game have the actual
shoes from the guy that ran you over you
can say you know what these are the
shoes but but what's weird is when he
lies down to go to sleep he puts those
shoes on his chest because that's what
he remembers about you running him over
well he knows where they fit he he's
gota kind of knows where to put him
right wait why didn't you GNA kill me he
gonna kill me you know that right no no
he's not because we saw what happened on
the football field uh but why didn't you
exchange Jerseys did you ever do that
when you played you know what I did a
little bit not a whole lot um it was
hard for me to get the Jersey off
so so I wasn't doing much exchanging uh
from that standpoint so the shoes were
the right thing to do and what I did was
you know a lot of guys do uh the jerseys
and so I just I thought so much of of
Brian that I went into their locker room
afterwards uh out of respect for him and
wanted to change uh the shoes because I
just I felt that there was some things
uh that are espe you can get a Jersey
from a guy but when you get somebody's
shoes it it it you know it means
something and it shows something so I
wanted to do something a little
different uh so I exchange different
things from with different people I'm
sure herlocker saw you coming into the
locker room it's like you're the last
guy he wants to see coming in how about
you send him a Christmas card not hey
Brian here's the shoot I ran you over
with the key is to immediately get right
back in there and make them feel good so
that they don't hate you so the longer
you go without that that connection they
gets they get madder and madder right
they get more pissed off so I was glad I
diffused it early but you never did this
you didn't do this with Ray Lewis did
you no absolutely not that the Ravens
you would I would not be caught dead in
that l room I tell you that but well no
you might be caught dead in that locker
room that's that's right I would be dead
if I was in the locker room I promise
you that but I I will say this about Ray
Lewis we have become great
friends um and we were friends then we
just were friends that really didn't
speak to each other um but we have
become great friends uh since our time
on the field great to talk to you as
always Merry Christmas to you thanks for
joining us boss thank you appreciate it
that's a Jerome Bettis Hall of Fame
running back MN his golf tournament blue
and gold
classic.com take a break play of the day
up next